so I have a serious case of
oneit um really really sad and depressed
and having a hard time to get over it I
saw the writing on the wall um dated for
a one and a half year Broadway
actress um and got dumped after it so I
wish I had more time to tell how it get
through that but uh plugged in I was was
married relate a lot to your to your
story uh got divorced went through the
divorced grinder wait you married this
girl that you got the oneitis for no no
no no no I was married uh yeah and got
divorced and then all my friends went to
her side I was leaving in I I'm living
in the US and didn't know the culture
didn't have any friends so what saved me
was going back to the gym I was out of
shape so got really in good shape and
start to dat again and then got involved
with with a second chick which is
related to another guy that was relating
to which one did you have oneitis for
this is the one after the marriage no
that that was the third one that was
after this pet mom where do you live so
just I live in the US right now I'm in
Brazil uh spend some some time with my
dad that's really sick so okay seems
like and where in the US did you live
when you were dating this uh chick at
the one
is4 um to live in New York I I live in
Seattle um I work I'm a rocket man I I
work in a rocket company um
for wait sorry she lives in New York but
you lived on the other side of the
country yeah yeah so it was crazy you
had a long dist relationship yeah so
first talked about that before yeah have
you seen my videos on longdistance
relationships I did I read your book and
from the start I told her she was there
she did a show we got together because
of an app and I told her I don't do long
distance and right from the start I read
on the app she was bisexual she was okay
with um ethical no monog no enm ethical
no monog she want go bang other guys
yeah anyways I I said this would be a so
why you take her seriously if you know
she's all about that sort of
Lifestyle at first I didn't it's like
Rob was saying I I I decide to indulge
and I had a casual thing and then she
went back to New York but man she was
gorgeous she was feminine and I never
was treated like that she was burn she
she had really burning desire for me um
after she went to New York I said okay
that's chick's got genuine burning
desire for you she doesn't want to go
and [__] other guys no and other guys
are legit invisible to her exactly and
she went back to New York I said that's
it she said no what we I like you we had
a good thing uh let's keep talking I
said no I I've been there before I don't
want one week one week after she bought
a flight ticket to see me in Seattle she
came she asked me can I see you I'm
going to Florida and I decid to do a in
Seattle can I see you said man okay
never had that she went she was gorgeous
B my my bones off throughout the week um
yeah I really I I was indulging I said
okay I won't take her seriously but
like really really slowly she was I was
getting into her and after that she said
okay come see me in New York I never
been to New York before um I'll get I
was I never went to see a show in
Broadway I'll get you a a ticket to see
a show with me Broadway I went and then
how long did you dat her for one and a
half year one and a half year and when
was the last time you saw her uh we
ended this three months ago and never
never talk to her anymore but man it's
been really really hard because yeah no
I can tell I can tell in your voice um
so about three months ago was the last
time you talked to her so why did you
guys break up like like what was the
reason I wish I could talk more but I
decide to put boundaries there was so
many things so many built up like she
would do shows like volunteer shows
where she would uh strip for money it's
like Broadway births a lot of actors go
there and strep and said I don't like
that I don't want that but it's for a
good cause I don't care how old are you
Rod I'm 45 and how old was she uh she
was 42 but she she's really2 and she's
and she's still behaving like this look
man you're like love can look like crazy
right like a lot of people mistake crazy
for love and the way you're describing
the runup like the crazy elements of of
it guys get caught up on that you have
some great sex she love bombs you I love
you so much and all that kind of
[__] and then you're like all of a
sudden she's saying this you're getting
the experience but then she goes and
does something else like she's stripping
for other men or she wants to go and
sleep with other men because she wants
to be ethically non- monogamous right
and that's what crazy looks like right
it's like say one thing and then do
something completely totally different
out of character right holding you I
love you I want to be with you you know
we're going to make something out of
this and then you know like next weekend
she's another city and she's stripping
for I know she didn't see any other guys
I I do know she didn't because I tried
to I ended with her three times every
time I I finished she brought she bought
a flight ticket and come to see me and B
my so again crazy crazy can look like
love like you don't want to confuse it
yeah you have to believe the actions
right if if you set a boundary and you
say look I can't take a girl seriously
that's going to be taking off her
clothes and stripping for other guys
then a girl that's got genuine burning
desire that doesn't have any kind of
issues or mental issues or BPD or
anything like this she' be like yeah you
know what you're right because I value
this relationship and you're that
important to me that I can stop doing
that exactly exactly and and didn't end
there what ended is that one day she
decided to go for a dinner with a single
friend with her and then she sent me
pictures oh there is a Dance Festival
and I'm Dan dancing with the guy said no
I don't want that yeah I don't want to
environment yeah look dude what I mean
if a chick's not going to follow your
lead she's not going to enter your frame
she's gonna like a good relationship is
going to be easy it's not supposed to be
hard you're not supposed to be fighting
over stupid [__] she's not going to be
you know stepping out of bounds and
doing things that compromise Your Love
okay she's going to follow your lead
right she's going to basically follow
the um boundaries that you said you know
I can't I can't be taking a girl serious
the only reason why you took her
seriously though R is because you don't
because you didn't have better options
right exactly if you had better options
if you had more abundance you would have
looked at it and been like that looks
like
crazy I might spend some time with it
have some fun but that's crazy I'm not
going to get attached I'm not going to
invite it my life I've got these options
over here yeah that that that's part of
what happened I I I try not to take her
seriously I was trying I I was dating
other girls too but not to to as good as
her you know dude there's there's
there's 4 billion women on the planet
you can't tell me that there's not
something better than this hoe a 42y old
hopping disagree with you
your I me Seattle it's a walk City it's
depressing most of so I think this is
the question I want to ask you
because from your shows the the ladies
night it's horrible and I never dated a
girl that was feminine uh she really
took good care of me she would cook me
meals she she would buy can you get out
of Seattle and go work for another
company can you work for Elon Musk and
do SpaceX I don't think he's based on
Seattle exactly I'm thinking of that
like there there's I I have an option to
the current company I'm working they
have office in La I'm off going there I
mean La is better than Seattle but not
by much like you want to get to a state
that's like more Texas Tennessee Florida
yeah like you know try to find a red
State see if you can get into like a red
state
where's where's the SpaceX based Texas
Texas but mainly La so what I realize
yeah see if you can get your ass down to
Texas
man what I want is a big Center where
there's Arts entertainment these are
what I realized where women that take
good care of their body and are healthy
no no no no no I'm going to stop you
there look Arts entertainment chicks
they're all they're sorry they're mostly
all like you've just described they're
usually very attractive because they
move and they dance and they take care
of themselves sort of thing but they've
been with a lot of dudes they're
constantly out partying and dancing like
look when they're out dancing and
they're doing these shows they're
advertising themselves these these these
artsy attractive dancing Broadway show
kind of like look I've dated a few of
them I know exactly what you're dealing
with yes they're hot yes they're great
in the bedroom blah blah blah and all
that sort of stuff but they're not
long-term Rel Rel ship material like
you're not going to be able to invite
him to your life you're not going to
have a good relationship with them they
are going to be a pain in your ass
they're going to step out of the bounds
you can't control me they're all
feminists they're all yeah they are it's
not if they're a feminist it's to what
degree they're a feminist and if you
look at my red flag list there's at
least three red flags on that list that
almost every Broadway you know
dancer artsy sort of chick is going to
violate right so uh like get comfortable
like there's lots of very feminine
attractive women with a nice figure that
don't do that stuff that are that are
just into self-care for the Optics of I
want to be healthy and I want to have a
nice looking body for my guy not for
15,000 guys right like they do exist out
there um but I mean if you want to lean
into The Artsy cities and the gals like
you're going to be dealing with that
more and more you have to understand Rod
there's there's four billion women on
the earth it's incredibly arrogant to
think for a minute that she's the only
one that can ever exist for you there's
loads and loads and loads of other way
better women out there I guarantee you
in 5 years time you're going to look
back on this and be like what the [__]
was I thinking man I hope so because I'm
getting old I'm not getting any younger
uh age plays a role in for the sample
that you see on your shows for ladies
night man most women that are really
attractive and and I don't want to lower
my standards because I take care of
myself you know I I want someone that is
beautiful well there's well there's lots
of beautiful women that I've seen on
that show that are an absolute train
wreck like we've had some hot women on
that show and they're just like there
was at least two or three that just
broke down into tears and like like
sobbing crying on the show and that's
why I get so depressed because like
emotional
damage that's that's what you're G to
deal with and it's like cool man that's
that's what it is I see it now I'm going
to keep it at arms length and I'm not
going to fall for her [__] and
you're not fully Rod like I'll be honest
with you no woman today will ever have
control over me when you're fully
unplugged you'll never have one itis
again because you see relationships you
see women you see these Dynamics for
what they truly are right they say that
you can love women or you can understand
them but it's very very difficult to do
both I figured out how to do both right
they will never have control over me
ever again you need to get to that place
where you have an understanding and you
create an agreement with yourself
that you don't allow yourself to get to
that place ever again because you keep
difficult bratty like women that are red
flags like a walking Chinese Communist
parade like you keep them out of your
life you don't you don't fall for their
[__] no I agree with you man and I'm
really trying hard it's only been it's
only been three months Rod I guarantee
within like there's an old saying that
you know somebody told this to me when I
had oneitis years ago they said you know
if you dat a girl for like three years
or something like that it's probably
going to take you three years to like
totally forget about her right so you
dated this chick for a year and a half
you got another you know like year and
change before you're totally going to
forget about her but you will forget
about her it's just a matter of time
focus on you focus on your hobbies focus
on building a good network if Seattle is
not for you you don't like you know like
the wokeness you don't like the city
then move to another city man like as
far as we know dude this is the only
life we get maybe there's a bonus around
when we die who knows but as far as you
know when we're walking this Earth this
is what we get so don't waste it living
your life for some [__] company you
know lining their pockets with gold
working on problems that you may not
totally care about because the thing
that you care about right now that's
holding you back is some random hoe in
New York that takes off for clothes for
other men that's what she is see her for
what she is understand her for what she
is take her off the pedestal knock her
down and move on with your life and live
it for yourself I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
newer to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out